[Music]
welcome back river babes
I'm your host Liana Galera and this is
your Sweetwater secrets preview show for
Episode three or four chapter 39 in The
Midnight Club aka our super epic
flashback episode I'm young Ellis in
case you couldn't tell
now I missed hearing your kisses and
kisses last week since Riverdale was on
a break but I hope you all had a
wonderful Halloween and are ready to
dive back into all the GMG craziness now
today I'm bringing you an exclusive
interview with the stars machen Amick
and Lily Reinhart spilling everything
you need to know about the midnight club
and then I'm teasing you with my three
clues about this time-traveling episode
now spoiler alert this episode has some
of my favorite Riverdale moments of all
time but first let's take a look at your
kisses kisses comments and theories from
episode 303 chapter 38 as above so below
first up it's easy wrote hisses to
everyone in charge at that stupid prison
is it even legal to make inmates fight
each other and don't even get me started
on the guards ah nope is he not legal at
all but then again the laws don't really
seem to apply to Riverdale do they now
it is he also added kisses to Cheryl and
Tony for being serpent Queens together
while bug head is busy with G and G yes
you know so many of you River rapes also
sent kisses to miss Veronica for
acknowledging Shoni as a power couple
because they are who would you have lead
us through those super dark times of
junior year next up Sandra Valley Cee Lo
posted hisses to Ethel for kissing
Jughead was I the only one annoyed no I
think we were all quite peeved by Miss
princess ethylenes behavior in that
episode is that why you guys are pissed
and rogue vortex 58 commented with a new
theory and wrote I think that the
coroner started G&G with the parents and
now his son is taking over
who else could gain access to the
hospital so easily and be able to
provide the players with poison
interesting theory now I do think that
it was really bizarre that they recast
the coroner with a younger actor so
maybe this was done for a reason
or maybe not at this point I don't know
what I'm supposed to make sense and
believe anymore I don't even know but
we're just gonna keep going
Jessica Bowles wrote in and said I think
we shouldn't blame Evelyn just yet we
have no proof that she's bad only that
she's been raised by bad people there
might be a chance that she doesn't know
the full extent of what her father does
Jessica I totally hear where you're
coming from and to be honest I'm loving
the introduction of Evelyn to this
storyline
I think the actress who plays her Zoe to
Grand Mason is giving us the perfect
blend of creepy yet intriguing and like
I said last week I love to hate Evelyn
but I mean that is a compliment yeah no
worries I totally understand
lastly Meaghan Khun PUD hisses Juno
phallus kiss phallus is the longest
relationship build-up that started in
season one and they still haven't had
one kiss ah yeah that's lame and you
know it's also kind of lame slash
interesting is it's looking like the
first time we're ever gonna see phallus
kiss is actually when lily and Cole are
playing young Alice and FP in this
week's flashback episode I'm not sure
how I feel about this but it's in the
promo so let's take a look it was our
junior year Fred Andrews Alice Smith
Hermione Gomez Forsythe Pendleton Jones
jr. welcome to saturday detention our
lives are about to change forever
the world was a very different place and
we were very different people so many
kisses in just one trailer now since our
stars are actually playing the younger
versions of their parents it was a
little confusing when I first watched
this but I spy Alice and FP smooching
and Alice and Fred locking lips okay
Alice get it girl
and you know why I caught up with both
girls who are playing Alice in this
episode star's matron amick and Lily
Reinhardt and here's a little tease of
what they told me we discover in episode
302 when all the parents of Rubidoux get
together which was so great to see them
all in the same room yeah but they've
had experiences with Griffins and
gargoyles beforehand what can you tease
about what secrets they're hiding and
what the Midnight Club is so the
Midnight Club was when we all were in
detention together and they uncovered
this secret game that everybody started
playing and it really takes you into a
dark twisted mental space and then we
ended up losing a life along the way
[Music]
[Applause]
that's what the flashback episode is is
the parents forming the Midnight Club
yeah and how that came to be I'll be
bringing you even more scoop from Lily
in machen talking about some spoilery
moments during our next Sweetwater so
after you watch the episode come back
for that but until then let's see if you
can crack my three clues about episode
304 now number one red-hot rage leads
one character into two cat fights number
two there is a truly surprising lip-lock
can you guess which to share smooch and
number three the cherry on top of this
episode is finally uncovering one
characters cringe-worthy family tree and
now we're done check back with me after
you've watched chapter 39 the midnight
club for even more scoop from the stars
because I was actually on set for that
episode and can finally share some
behind-the-scenes moments but for now do
me a favor and give this video a like
and then hit subscribe so you never miss
an episode of Sweetwater secrets and now
tell me
thoughts in the comments below what do
you think is gonna happen in this
flashback episode do you have any new
theories about the gargoyle King and can
you decipher my three clues
tell me and I'll see you after the
episode River babes
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]